this whole tablets are for work thing is
really starting to catch on first
Microsoft's had the surface then lots of
other Windows manufacturers started
making similar to and one laptop tablet
hybrids then Apple maybe I've had Pro
and now Google has the pixel seed the
pixel see isn't huge like the iPad pro
or the surface it's actually a fairly
normal looking tablet a really good one
actually super high res 10.2 inch screen
super fast and video processor aluminum
body good speakers the latest version of
Android it's handsome and rugged and
it's screen has this unique root 2
aspect ratio that makes it much more
usable in either orientation as a tablet
it's great it'll last a few days it's
light and thin and sturdy it does all
the tablet things and Android should do
truthfully the iPads better for the same
price but this one's good too but Google
imagines the pics we'll see is something
more a productive tablet a tablet you
can do work on that's why in addition to
the $500 pixel see Google's also making
a hundred and fifty dollar keyboard
attachment that uses Bluetooth and a
really clever magnet to turn the tablet
into something like a laptop but even
with the attachment the pixel see isn't
a work device it's partly the hardware's
fault the keyboard layout takes some
getting used to and just isn't big
enough to really be comfortable
the screens also not big enough to do
real intense work much less two things
at once this is more like a low-end
entry-level kind of computer but the
real problem is Android which just isn't
a very good tablet operating system very
few of the apps are optimized for the
big screen or even for working in
landscape the OS itself looks strange on
the big screen having Google now
accessible from anywhere is handy
especially since you can just say okay
Google and jump straight to search but
otherwise there's not much here for
tablets there is hope though the pixel
see is made by the same team that made
the Chrome
pixal and that teams job has always been
to make amazing hardware almost as a
tease for Google's software developers
look how good this could be it says if
only the software we're going to the
Chromebook nailed it it proves Chrome OS
can be a formidable laptop for getting
work done now Google's trying to do the
same thing with tablets to prove that
they can be portable easy fun and crazy
productive Google made a good tablet but
what a good tablet is is changing and it
requires good software for work and for
fun Android is not good tablet software
not yet anyway
maybe now that they have good hardware
that start working on